[Applause]
okay
ethan hawke the greatest generation has
given society so much has Hollywood seen
its own greatest generation yes what do
you need I don't know what that means
they the great it like no nevermind
Duncan Hunter we know the Democrats are
guilty of identity politics what
responsibility should the left take for
white politics are so polarized today I
I think when we found out so Democrats
had control of Congress for like 50
years in 94 Newt Gingrich into that I
think once everybody figured out that
anybody could win any election that's
what created the the massive polarity
that we have now where you have two
different sides and either side can win
any election right well anybody can but
you must admit that the Republicans
cheat more no I don't have to admit that
really away voter suppression
oh you don't you don't think this voter
suppression how about in California with
illegal immigrants being registered to
vote and then vote has been studied and
it's not true it is true well Trump says
there were three million illegal votes
his numbers right but I think that it's
a high number it's a high now it's a
lower number it's not that on is it up
to a million I don't know I don't know
the number but I don't know no sooner we
know it's a problem yeah but if it's one
well I've seen it happen in San Diego on
the border just south there I mean I
live in San Diego on the border and they
do register illegal immigrants to vote
in our elections speaking of the border
today Democrats okay speaking of the
border all right let me ask let me ask a
question about the border cuz we didn't
get to this we didn't get to this issue
this week and this is your district is
right on the border as you say Jeff
Sessions announced this week we are
having a very new policy and it doesn't
look to me very American and that is
splitting up families at the border if a
family of Mexican people are coming
trying to get across the border we're
going to send the kid off in one
direction and the mother to jail and put
the baby in baby detention center
splitting up families he's wrong against
yeah let me tell you okay
I'm gonna get booed in one second we
should sing really the whole family if
the parents are here illegally you don't
separate the family you send the whole
family back and if they want the kid to
stay with a guardian or somebody here
like someone that's already here in this
country until they're 18 years old they
can do that but the family up I would
send everybody back and say apply
everybody said this policy is it just to
be as big a prick as we can to send the
message you try to get to this country
we'll split your family up then I go -
maybe maybe yeah
I'm glad you admit that okay can I just
ask congressman what about refugees what
about people who actually are fleeing
dangerous circumstances don't we have a
tradition about opening our powders I've
been working for five or six years to
help hard to try to get people that are
translators in Iraq Afghanistan Syria
name your place that have helped with
the US military tons and now their
families had to move to India in the
Pakistan blue they're not to escape
people in Afghanistan we've been trying
to get them refugee status in the US and
that's hard to do you still people that
are not over here yet that are overseas
who should be here so that's something
that we should do as Americans but
remember this is not about Mexico it's
about people from the entire world
wanting to come to a better place and us
not wanting them to bring the same
problems that they're fleeing from with
them here and there are Spain's problems
they want a country ruled by law that's
what makes us safe that's what I want
here okay yes and I've certainly met
people from other countries who say I do
not want the [ __ ] that I fled coming
back here I threw that veil off when I
got here don't make me wear it here
ethan hawke what are the key social
differences you noticed between the
United States and Canada as someone who
lives in both countries what a great
question
you know you should be a politician you
know you come on a show like this and
you wonder what you're gonna get hit
with you know and that that's so
interesting to me because I do I have a
place in Nova Scotia that we spend
summers at and I have for a long time
and one of the things that's amazing
there is your you know what you would
call rural people lobster man fisherman
hunters you know guys who's out in the
sticks this place Mystics and the people
there are environmentalists and they are
extremely educated in in protecting
their environment and it really because
it's their liberty make it really easy
everyone you have to recycle they have a
bag for compost they have a bag for
plastic they have a bag for their four
different things and you have to do it
or you get a fine so you can go to a
hunting Shack and a you know a
hootenanny at 4:00 in the morning people
are playing there smoking pot they're
drinking and they're putting their
recycling where it belongs they make it
really easy to do the right thing and
that is is really exciting
okay where ever care about the
environment servation it's not an
environmentalist but that's what people
who hunt like I do all kinds of things
but conservationists I want the wild
land to be beautiful I want deer all
over so I can shoot them and eat them
and still have plenty more for everybody
else really I mean great hunters and
fishermen
yes country and they're the ones who
should be leading us the cause and if
look if you if you eat what you shoot
that's no different than someone who
goes to the supermarket so that's a
that's a hypocrisy fact why doesn't have
antibiotics it does exactly right all
right we should do a better job of
putting trash cans at bus stops in this
country we sure yeah we don't we don't
make it easy done cycling things I don't
think but well you know go why do you
think that you know the Teddy Roosevelt
is a great model of a Republican leader
in ecology and everything why isn't the
Republican administration take that more
seriously like how are they okay with
what Scott Pruett is doing because the
the history is a great history
Republican Party
[Music]
in protecting your right to hunt and
making that more available I just I feel
like that is a place where you could
really leave so the Department of the
Interior that a Navy SEAL has former
congressman Navy SEALs now the head of
the Interior and he is doing that I mean
he's a conservationist those groups like
Safari Club International they they try
to bring more elephants around they try
to bring more deer they're introducing
antelope back into San Diego in the way
next year like 1,000 years ago Beth
Scott do you think he should resign no
yes so over in station aligns that
there's all the expenses on everybody
and this is it's getting ridiculous
they're not [ __ ] and that's very
attractive to people and Democrats need
to learn that skill tutor us a little
bit one more environmental question the
I don't know if you saw but this week
the CDC says diseases borne by ticks
fleas and mosquitoes whenever you stop
mosquitoes in California's one of the
great things about it now I see
mosquitoes out of control and these
carry really horrible diseases that they
don't have a clue how to fix and you go
camping or even in the years to come
just staying at home you're gonna this
is gonna be more prevalent this is
because of global warming because when
winters are shorter that there's more
environment that's friendly to these
bugs for a longer time it's gonna bite
you in the ass literally I the air is
you know it's not something that which
people can cordon off that's what I
don't get about why Republicans why the
Koch brothers are not environmentalists
they can't have their own air you can't
get away from this [ __ ] it's gonna get
everybody using bottled air possible for
more to
send mosquito yes I am that's a global
in the New York Times that talks about
this they didn't mention global warming
once there wasn't the word climate
change wasn't used the word temperature
was used one time and this one of them
is because no I'm telling it bill no no
I promise you it wasn't in there they
said people flying now from other places
and the ease of access in travel and and
and the world being flattered that is
what it has really led to this the one
big elephant in this room that we're not
talking about is money in politics but
Republicans really have have led the way
big money hey I think the Republican
Party has been much too corporatized but
nah they're the way too close to Wall
Street way too close we we used to be
the party of not free trade of fair
trade of mere trade what Trump's doing
now which I dig I dig was doing on steel
on tariffs on NAFTA side I think what
he's doing that's gotta be like yeah
just go back to corporations can't
donate regular and millionaires
shouldn't be a little run against guys
like me
McCain used to be that was his big thing
but really yeah that was the faster one
bill that they then they got it alright
thank you everybody thank you
[Applause]